Good afternoon and welcome.
My name is Nancy McDonald. I'm with the
League of Women Voters of Nevada and we
are hosting this event. Thank you so
much for being here.
As you may know, there are four
candidates for the
the race of Sparks mayor.
Three of them are here and you will hear
from them and get a feel for what they
would bring to this important office.
Wendy Rossum I had a prior commitment
that she couldn't get out of apologizes
for not being here so she can be glad to
talk to anybody individually.
You can reach her at
wendyformayor2016@yahoo.com
if you want.
This is our lovely moderator,
Jane Young who is with the Reno Gazette
Journal. We have people from KTVN
Channel 2 here to be broadcasting this
forum so the people that could not join
us could
get a feel for what the candidates are
going to be sharing.
Housekeeping,
bathroom is down that hall.
If you don't feel well,
speak up.
If you need to make a stop, please do.
Take care of yourself. I do expect
George Guthrie from the Registrar of
Voters office to be here
and he will be answering questions at
the end of this afternoon about the
voting process because some of that is a
little confusing.
My colleague
Brittany who's
doing registration for if you haven't
registered to vote or you need to
re-register, out there she and I can
answer your questions too that will be
the authority. And
let [clears throat] the candidates
introduce themselves and I will turn
this over to Jane.
No, I'll I'll keep that one.
Did you draw numbers or Yes,
drew numbers. They both drew numbers.
Who was here first? They were here
first.
No, we just happened to draw. One and
two.
Um hi everybody. Um my name is Jane
Young and I'm with the Reno Gazette
Journal. I'm the moderator today. I'm
going to read out just the quick format
of how this is going to go just so
everybody knows. Um each candidate will
give a 3-minute opening statement with
order determined by drawing numbers and
the timekeeper will alert the candidate
when time is almost up.
The moderator, me, will ask two
questions of all candidates with orders
with the order rotated and answer
answers are limited to 2 minutes each.
Audience members will ask questions of
the candidates after that. Please keep
your questions brief and candidates will
have 2 minutes to answer
and then the order of the answers will
then be rotated. If time permits,
audience members may ask questions of a
single candidate with answer limited to
2 minutes.
Each candidate will give a 2-minute
closing statement at the end and then
the last 30 minutes will be devoted to
questions about the voting process to be
answered by George Guthrie of Washoe
County
Registrar's office.
And then I think you already mentioned
the rules. Yes, so obviously everyone is
welcome. We're happy to have you all
here. Thank you so much for coming and
we're excited to hear you guys'
questions for the candidates.
Be sure to show respect for all
candidates, other audience members and
facility property. No name calling, no
booing, no shouting, no interrupting. I
don't think we'll have that problem.
No violence and no threats of violence.
No video or audio recording of the forum
without prior approval. Just that just
keeps the whole thing a little bit
cleaner, more simple.
And then the room must be left clean
with furniture back in place. So.
Thank you so much again for coming
everybody.
Okay, I guess we'll start with opening
statements. I think Charlene's first,
right?
Okay, is it on? Yes. Okay. Um I did, I
drew number one. I guess it's lucky
number. Um my name is Charlene Bibeau. I
am currently a Sparks City Councilwoman.
I've been on the council for 12 years.
Uh I grew up in Sparks. I was a little
girl,
oldest of six kids, grew up in in Sparks
way back in the in the day. So seen a
lot of changes since I was a little
girl. Um
After
So I grew up there, I came back, I went
to the university. So I'm a graduate of
the University of Nevada, Reno. I have
my bachelor's degree. I was a student
athlete
at the university competing in
gymnastics. Nobody even remembers we had
gymnastics and I had no scholarship yet.
I met my husband there. He was a
football player and
we're both student athletes at the
university. We just celebrated our 46th
wedding anniversary. We have two sons
and following college I was hired by
American Airlines and I was a flight
attendant for 46 years. Excuse me, 42
years. Been married 46, 42 years
with American Airlines.
Great career
and
really enjoyed that. Retired just 7
years ago from American Airlines.
I live now in Sparks with my husband
who's retired and have So I have gone
from a little girl to living here right
after
when I started my career, working mom,
raising my boys in Sparks,
really involved in the community, over
40 years of volunteer service in my
community and
just Sparks is home and Sparks is what
I'm passionate about and I want to
continue serving so I'm running for
mayor
because I want to continue serving the
residents of the city of Sparks. Thank
you all for being here. Really
appreciate it.
Just leave it on.
Okay.
I I'm Ed Lawson. I was raised in Las
Vegas, Nevada. I got a full ride
scholarship to Colorado State, left Las
Vegas in 1978.
Met my wife
43 years in August this year in college.
We dated since we were 19. Raised both
of our boys here, both graduated from
UNR. We have lovely football games when
Nevada plays Colorado State. It's always
a lot of fun at our house.
But um
I started working for Motorola two-way
radios out of college in in the Las
Vegas area. Worked there for 2 years. My
wife got
held up at gunpoint and she said find a
new place to live or you can come visit
your kids in Colorado. So we ended up
here, moved to Sparks 1989. We love it
here.
We love raising our family here. My
oldest son is training to be a doctor
and I just got word he got engaged a few
weeks ago and I'm going to get sent one
doctor out for training, we're going to
get two back in the area. So when they
get finished their training, they want
to move back to Sparks and help out the
community. But
other than that been on the council, got
involved with the council because I was
the government relations person for
Young Electric Sign Company
and saw how the government worked at the
local level and wasn't exactly
impressed. So I uh
said, you know what? Rather than sit on
the sidelines and
about it, let's get involved and
make something happen and that's what
I've been doing ever since I got
elected.
I need this or not, I have a loud voice.
My name's Diana Mackey and I'm running
for mayor of Sparks. I grew up in
Columbus, Ohio back in the day when
Columbus, Ohio had 150,000
people and now it's over 100. I went to
college. I was the first one in my
family to go to college. I went to Miami
University in Oxford, Ohio and got a
bachelor's degree.
Then I got married, stayed home, had two
children. One of them is sitting right
here. The other one's in the Bay Area.
I started my career being a headhunter
because I had a degree in speech and
English and broadcast journalism but
there weren't many careers available for
women in broadcast journalism back then.
So I became a librarian for a short
time, had my children. When I went back
to work, I got a job being a headhunter.
Then I got recruited [clears throat] by
a company called American Electric
Power.
They were moving all of their employees
from New York City to Columbus, Ohio. So
because my children were playing sports
in high school and going to Ohio State
University, I commuted from Columbus,
Ohio to New York City for 3 years.
Then I got recruited by Ernst & Young,
the accounting firm. I spent 10 years
with them. Most of my career has been
spent in college relations, human
resources, working with people at all
different levels within a corporation. I
then got my master's degree in
administration and it's been helpful to
me in my career. So my children moved to
California.
So when I was 50 years old, I packed up
my Jeep and moved to San Francisco and
was hired by dot coms.
I don't have much time left but I just
want to say I am not a career
politician.
I'm a career person who has worked in
the private sector but I have been a
lifelong volunteer with the Democratic
Party and I've also been a community
organizer everywhere I've lived and most
recently in Sparks. So I want to thank
everyone for coming. I want to thank all
of you involved and I will enjoy telling
you more about myself.
>> [applause]
>> Thank you guys so much. That was great.
She started. Okay, so we got What side
do we start on?
>> We don't know. I think
>> [laughter]
>> I think we'll to 3-2-1 reverse. So,
we'll start with Diana. Okay. And then
we'll go Ed and then we'll go Charlene.
Okay, so the first question is
what do you see as the biggest challenge
facing What What do you see is the
biggest challenge facing Sparks and how
will you address it? And then you have 2
minutes to answer. So, 2 minutes. Okay,
the biggest issue I see
is that Sparks has no money.
I blame that on tax abatements
being given out to companies that moved
out to USA Parkway.
I blame that on an outdated system for
collecting property taxes
and I blame a lot of that on
the legislature.
Because cities cannot raise taxes, they
can only raise fees.
So, what I want to do is I have a friend
who is running for the legislature. He
wants to have a state lottery.
He's gone around to all the casinos and
talked to them about that and a lot of
money goes to California
by people going over the Gold Ranch to
buy their lottery tickets.
I also would like to see
people look at maybe and I know Mayor
Losses talked about this a little bit.
It might be time to change the property
tax formula.
Also, there's a C tax, the compliance
tax.
Um
that needs to be redone, too. So, I
think a lot of the things we can do have
to be done with the legislature. I think
the city and I have to commend them for
this. They've cut as far as they can.
And they're short of police officers,
they're short of fire people. So, I
think a lot of things have to be
examined, but I would start with the
legislature and
building relationship with them. And I
have to say that I know most of them and
I also know both of the people that
could win the governorship
pretty well.
Thank you.
So, there's no doubt it's our property
tax system. It's broken, it's
antiquated, it doesn't work.
Um you know, now we have to build a
house every 5 to 6 years
a new house so that it can pay for the
house that was built 5 or 6 years ago
because of inflation and the way our tax
system actually gets abated. If you have
a new house that's under 50 years old,
we collect 1 and 1/2% property tax
increase. That's the most you can ever
pay in a year. Uh I challenge you to run
a business on a percent and a half. It
just does not work. It you don't keep up
with inflation.
Our expenses have gone up by 50% 54%
roughly in the last 5 years. Our
revenues have gone up around 36, 37%.
So, that's a trend that's trending for
the all of the state in Nevada, not just
Sparks, but it's also trending in every
other city within Nevada except the Las
Vegas Clark County area
because they decided to put in a uh
additional tax for Metro PD that started
it got passed in 1971. The reason I know
this is cuz my dad was on the police
department 1970, became Metro in 1972
and then that three more times Las Vegas
and Clark County residents passed three
more funding sources for police. If we
just take police out of our budget right
now, that's $48 million
out of a $120 million budget. Uh we
would have no financial problems. But as
soon as you say we're going to put a tax
on, people start running for the doors
and or they run to get their pitchforks
to
uh run us out of town. But it it's at
some point
the pain is going to be worse to stay
the same than the pain of change and
that's what I always say. So, uh
one day
will we get there? Who knows, but the
state legislature controls our life.
So, I would agree absolutely the number
one issue we have had has been budget
and like the mayor stated, those numbers
of of inflation has been our our worst
enemy in the last several years
especially. Well, all of us when you're
buying groceries, when you're putting
gas in your car, whatever your expenses
are, think about it on a city level and
if you're we're putting gas in vehicles,
we're buying things for the city, those
expenses for us have gone up
extraordinarily and our revenue coming
in, all we operate on are property taxes
and C tax, which is predominantly sales
tax. Um the property tax is is a broken
system. I totally agree with the mayor
and we've tried three times and I would
still like to go maybe
want to still pursue on the property tax
side, one of the things that we all feel
makes most sense is the reset on point
of sale, which sounds really complicated
and people are like, "What are you
talking about?"
If I sold my house today that I've lived
in for 35 years, my property tax
for those 35 years has depreciated. It
can go up 3% and then it depreciates
1.5. So, that's the 1.5 the mayor's
talking about. So, my depreciated
35-year depreciated property taxes are
what you would walk in and assume that
no matter what you pay for my house, you
could pay two or three times and you
probably would for my house and you're
going to pay mine you're going to assume
my property tax. That's not a new tax,
that's paying a fair tax of market
value, whatever the value of the house
is. So, we're looking at that. I will
say I don't I'm a fiscal conservative.
Every dollar I spend means a lot to me
and this last summer we got a
every elected in the state of Nevada got
a pay increase from the state from the
legislature. We had not had a raise in 7
years. I declined that raise which for
me just on the city council was $40,000.
I declined it this year because it would
come from the general fund of the city
of Sparks. Second time I've done I had a
smaller raise that I declined when I was
first elected. Thank Thank you. Sorry.
I'm stopped.
>> [laughter]
>> Got to talk faster.
I think that's
Um
we will now do let's do like Ed and then
Charlene and then Diana.
You want to rotate it up a little bit.
Um so, the second question is without
bashing your opponents,
what
what can you do or what makes you an
ideal leader for as Sparks city mayor?
It's all about relationships. The state
of Nevada is is everything happens with
a relationship.
You can know all the the
the senators and the assembly pieces
people from northern Nevada, but if you
don't know the southern Nevada people,
you're never going to get anything done
at the state legislature. I've developed
those relationships. I have the
governor's cell phone number. I have
Senator Rosen's cell phone number. I
have contact with all of our people up
here and and many, many of them down in
Las Vegas area. I was voted uh public
official of the year for 2025 by Nevada
League of Cities, which is my peers of
elected people. That's a big honor.
There's one one person given that award
each year. Um
I was also appointed to the uh train
light rail to train study by a Democrat
assemblyman from Las Vegas. So, it shows
that yeah, I am a Republican, but I've
been thrown out of the Republican Party
cuz I'm not Republican enough for them.
So, I work with whoever can help me cuz
all I care about is that big S on the
hill. It's what's what's in it for
Sparks. What can we do? Do we work
across the aisle? Yes, we do whatever it
takes to get things done. But uh
relationships and I believe I have that
experience.
I don't believe we need a
a a new
you know, part-time mayor or
a mayor in training. We need somebody
with the experience and ability to do
the job day one.
Oh, other way. Sorry.
So, I think what what sets me apart and
I've been on the council 12 years. So,
what the mayor's talking about as far as
relationships and meeting people and
knowing our electeds and our
congressional representatives,
I've had that opportunity in 12 years on
the council
to do that as well as 62 years in this
community. So, it goes to PTA, it goes
to all of my community connections. But
I think really my what my leadership is
is putting people first.
I listen.
I I really the city of Sparks doesn't
sell anything. We don't have a product
that we sell. We provide customer
service and customer service is my lane
of expertise. It's what I did for 42
years on an airplane. It's what I've
done for 40 years in uh all the
volunteer organizations that I've been
involved in.
It is my 12 years on the council has
always been putting people first. It's
communication, it's connection, it's
listening to people and I think those
skills connect us to each other and
honestly where we are today in this
country, um we need to be connected. We
need to not be so antagonistic against
you know, other people and the best part
of being on the council and the mayor,
it's a non-partisan position because
roads and fire department and code
enforcement are not Republican or
Democrat and we get an opportunity to
make decisions, the best decisions for
our businesses and for our people, not
for a political party.
I think I'd be really good at this job
because all my life I've worked with
people in neighborhoods.
When I wasn't working my corporate job,
I was out there being a community
organizer.
So, for the past
well, since I've moved here, I've been
part of a party where we have created
what we call precinct organizers.
I have trained most of them, and they
live in the communities. They're
community organizers all year long. And
to top that off, I am the area
coordinator for all the volunteers in
Sparks.
So, my
experience is actually being with the
people.
When I first started to run, I was going
to be a one-issue person. I was going to
save Red Hawk
from the horrible developer that wants
to rip up our golf course and build 6 7
800 homes on the golf course.
I've been involved with that
organization, the Wingfield Preservation
Association, to try to do what we can to
save it. But I think what I have is I
would take city council meetings make
them at 5:00 in the afternoon instead of
2:00, and I would have weekly um I'm
sorry, quarterly town halls at each of
the wards in Sparks to be closer to the
people.
Great. Thank you so much, guys. We're
going to do audience questions now. So,
does anybody have a question that they
want to ask my guest about? I can bring
this around. Yes, you're free to bring
it around.
>> [cough and clears throat]
>> First of all, thank you all for being
here and it's a good point
2 year version of Sparks.
Uh we currently have four jurisdictions
responsible for traffic planning,
traffic implementation, and road
maintenance. Even though regional
transportation commission, it's still up
to the four jurisdictions.
I'm curious to your opinion about
forming what's called a joint powers
authority
funded by
the cities, staffed by the cities, that
is actually regional transportation
planning and implementation.
They do the planning, they do the
implementation,
so we don't have
driving around and saying in the winter
time, "Oh, this isn't plowed because
this is Reno. Oh, this is NDOT."
What's your opinion about forming a JPA
and regional really regionalizing
traffic in in the area?
What order do you want to go in? We'll
start with Sharon.
Uh I would be open to getting more
details on that. I know the regional
transportation commission that the mayor
sits on is our only voice for the city
of Sparks.
Uh two elected from Reno, two from
Washoe County, just one voice for
Sparks. So, he's our lone voice so that
Sparks is heard at the table. And RTC
does uh is in charge of all of our main
arterials, but you're right. Sparks
Boulevard Vista, but then you go to
Pyramid, and that's NDOT. So, you take
another step to the state, and working
from local to state isn't always an easy
easy lift. In fact, it's usually a tough
one. And so, really the the more that we
can do um and we do a lot of things
regionally. We all sit on regional
boards, whether it's regional planning
or EDON or things that we have to work
as a region. So, so we really need our
voice, and we need Sparks' voice
especially at the table for all of this.
So, I would be interested in more
details. Is it more I'm always looking
for uh efficiencies, improvement, you
know, if it's more efficient, if it's
especially cost-wise, would it make
sense to do that for better decisions?
But we do on all of our regional boards
and commissions. That's why we're on
those, so that we bring Sparks' voice to
all the different things that we're
responsible for in in the Truckee
Meadows.
Next to Diane? We'll go to Diane.
I would have to study that more, too,
but I don't have a problem uh with
regionalization,
but I was part of a company at Ernst &
Young where we merged, and there's
nothing worse than a merger. Uh people
lose their jobs, they fight over power,
they do all kinds of things. But I think
we have to start looking at
regionalizing some of these services to
save money and not fight over
boundaries, but I don't think you do it
all at once. You might start with the
police, you might start with roads,
might go on with police department, but
I think gradually we're going to have to
do that to save money.
Um I also think that um
people have to be more open-minded about
it about sharing resources because
really the city, the county, and Sparks,
we have a revenue shortage. And uh I
have a relationship with my neighbor
once in a while, and that's Clara
Andriola. She's on the county
commission. And I know Alexis Hill. And
I think that we all have to work
together to find a solution for the
whole region, which I think eventually
is going to be
regionalized a lot of things.
>> [clears throat]
>> Yes.
So, I agree.
We have the devils in the detail,
obviously. You know, this we're studying
uh consolidation of fire right now. A
report has to be done by December of
this year to be presented to the
legislature.
That was done by Skip Daly, who's our
senator from Sparks.
Um I
it just depends. It's
The one thing I don't want to see is is
to get a board together and then have
two other entities have control of
Sparks' checkbook. And that would would,
you know, on a two-against-one scenario,
is oh, by the way, "We're going to run
four-man crews in Sparks now.
I can't afford $7 million. We can't
afford $7 million, and you can't afford
$7 million." It just doesn't work. So,
that you have to have on a consolidation
a separate funding source. That way that
organization can stay within their
spending means. That's why the the metro
police went and went and went. Their
their budget is somewhere around $5
billion to $6 billion each year for that
community. The but the community saw the
need for the police, they taxed
themselves. Even if we said today 100%
of people in Sparks said, "We want a
police tax." Guess what?
Doesn't matter. State has to say we can
do that. And if they say no, we can't do
it. So, we're at the mercy of the state
legislature. And I'm going to challenge
you right now. If you don't know who
your state assembly person is or your
state senator, find out, please. They
control your life a whole lot more than
the mayor of Sparks does.
Thank you. Thank you.
Um we'll have another question.
Ted, I I know you had proposed the toll
road at one time. Yep.
And there's an awful lot of
talk about about the road going out to
the industrial parkway. But I don't
think most people will understand where
it would go, what it would cost, and
what's involved. Could you
elaborate on that?
>> I'll tell you all of them in the region.
Oh, yeah. Well, he has more experience,
but Okay. Well, I I'll tell you how it
really came up is my council member
Donald Abbott is a historian, and he
loves going to those blue signs. And
almost a lot of the signs that are in
northern Nevada, there was a theme. This
was a toll road. This was a toll road.
This was So, we just started doing some
research into it, found out northern
Nevada had 117 toll roads at about the
time we became a state. And what the
state did was said, "You get to build
the road. You get to keep the revenue
for 20 years and then give the road back
to us." That's a clever way to uh build
a road.
What we are proposing is that a fast
pass, which is very common in
California, for all the employees that
work out at those tech industries, and
I've talked with the the heads out
there. Um I'm working closely with one
of the Tesla guys right now on this
other project that I hope will come to
fruition here soon, but
they would give their employees a a
pass, so they could drive on this toll
road. Their biggest problem they have
out there is retaining people. They'll
get people to go out there and work, and
then they get a two-hour commute for a
few months, and they go, "It's not worth
it. I'm missing kids' games. I'm missing
this. Um my life is on the road on a
12-mile stretch." So, there has to be an
alternative. There's a lot of people
that don't want it, but wait until I-80
starts construction for the next 5
years. That starts next spring. It's
going to get a whole lot worse.
What about the tax?
I um
I think there has to be an an
alternative. Even if we widen 80,
that's going to take forever, and that's
going to be a traffic jam, too. I don't
know how long it would take us to get
another road out there. Probably
cost it would probably cost $500 million
now, and by the time that everything got
approved, it would probably be upwards
toward a billion dollars. And I know the
people out where I live, this would be
out where I live, out in Wingfield. Um
people are real upset about the
environment being disrupted, uh their
commutes being disrupted, uh Vista being
a mess. So, I think here's my answer to
that problem.
There were too many abatements given to
all those companies out there without
them having plans
to get people to work quicker. And if
they wanted all those people to work out
there, they should have come up with
some kind of solution to get those
people to work, whether it be light
rail, um you know, we go up and down
Sparks. Uh my daughter lives in LA.
Sparks is like like an LA freeway all
the time. So, if we start building over
the years, it's going to be even worse.
So, I think we need alternative way to
get people out there to work because
probably in 10 years there'll be 50 to
80,000 people working out there.
And I'm totally against abatements
without some kind of
deal that helps us deal with the
infrastructure and gives us some of our
money back. I did a little bit of
research and not just this governor, but
other governors have given about a
billion dollars of revenue that we could
have gotten to do other things to these
companies to build out there.
So so the
the road you're talking about um
obviously one of the biggest headaches
on a daily basis is I-80 heading east.
And almost daily
accidents every day
from the amount [clears throat] of
people that are going out to the
Tri-Center for employment.
But that that problem I mean it's it's
hard because it's it's fallen on Sparks.
We didn't create it. It's not our you
know, we've got people try to our people
trying to get out there. But that I-80
corridor
is a mess and and and I should have
widened it 5 years ago. They knew Tesla,
Panasonic, they knew what was coming and
they're slow to react. That's a whole
'nother story. We have been looking at
because of our lands bill, which is all
the property east of Sparks,
we have looked as part of that lands
bill taking USA Parkway and having a
connector road that went north and then
dropped onto La Posada.
That
when the mayor when the toll road was
proposed, it was proposed as a toll
road. But that road itself has kind of
been in has been in our plans to also
connect it all the way over to North
Valleys eventually as another connector
to get people moving in and out of our
valley and to make it
you know, to make it safer. RTC has done
the initial studies and that's what
people were like really upset about
because
they they want alternative that I don't
support is going through Golden Eagle
Golden Eagle Park, which I don't want to
disrupt that gem in my in my ward and
coming over the hill and it would
interrupt some of the tribal land. We
have an MOU with the tribe on the lands
bill. So the La Posada, which would go
straight east before it turned south
wouldn't be right behind homes seems to
be possible alternative, but it's still
in the earliest feasibility. They don't
know where the money is. So a long way
to go, but that is the option I I would
ultimately support. Support.
>> [clears throat]
>> When
each of you talked about what you
thought your qualifications were what
make you the best candidate for mayor,
you mentioned relationships.
And
Mr. Valery, you said you've been on the
council for 12 years and I don't know
how long have you been mayor and on the
council? 6 years as mayor, 16 years on
the council. So you've been on the
council for you know,
affiliated with the 22 years. 16 years.
Total.
Okay.
16 years total.
Um I'm wondering
because you both touted your
relationships and that that's what is
important.
How come those relationships haven't
helped
move the state legislature
to allow more
the city to raise more revenue streams?
I mean what you know, what what good are
your relationships doing
your time on the council doing to make
change?
I don't Go ahead if you want.
>> [clears throat]
>> Is it my turn or first?
Okay.
No no no, I I get it. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> and the reality on the um
if any of you tried to ever do anything
with the legislature
and and Mr. Goodman over here is
laughing.
Um
It is a it is a really tough lift. We
are also controlled in our Nevada
legislature by Las Vegas by Southern
Nevada legislators. A lot of them
haven't been in office very long and
we really
we that that bill that we've tried on
the reset of property tax, we started
with Julia Ratti who was our state
senator and she moved it a little bit
and then it
draw nothing nothing happened. The next
time it stayed in the door in the drawer
of a chairman of a subcommittee and then
the last time with Nafta Anderson trying
to push it, we got it moved a little
bit. It is just an impossible lift down
there. I don't know and like I said, I
still think it's something we need to do
we need to do and we need to um
whether it's working with those
individual legislators, putting
pressure, the city's putting pressures
on the legis legislatures because it's
impacting everyone of everyone's
resident. Every assembly person then and
state senator lives somewhere that is
being harmed by this. So until our
voices are louder and we work in a
consortium of the bigger cities in
Nevada trying to move that needle uh
it's slow, but it's not but we're not
going to give up. We're not going to
give up. We're still going to push that
cuz that would help us ultimately. That
would be the biggest help would be
because we're not a tax entity. So we
cut expenses as much as we can, but to
increase that revenue,
we [clears throat] do need to do it at
the legislature. And we at the end of
the day we need more legislators here in
Nevada or Northern Nevada
uh we're stronger voices to help us do
that. So working as closely as we can
with those to just try to move the
needle, but it's a big lift.
>> [clears throat]
>> I I have a I just
I just want to say that [clears throat]
the state has grown and I think it's
time to start promoting a full-time
legislature.
We elect them, they go there.
They're there for a little 120 days.
Yeah, and then they're gone and then we
may elect new ones and if I feel like in
this state that they're always starting
over.
So I think we have to push to have a
full-time legislature or at least meet a
couple times a year because in my
opinion, nothing gets done.
Because it's stalled and unless you have
special sessions all the time, we're
still going to be frustrated because
we're losing out on money
and the new legislature when they get
elected in November, they're not going
to go in session I think what is it
February they go and they're there for
120 days.
>> Every other year. Yeah. So if I were
elected mayor of those 120 days, I'd be
there a lot. Nafta Anderson lives around
the corner from me too. So
I think we have the pressure not just
during legislative times, but all the
time and that's why we're we're telling
them, you know, find out who they are
and get in touch with them because
really if you're mayor or city council,
your hands are tied.
Short answer is Las Vegas.
Las Vegas controls the state. Until the
pain of change or staying the same is
greater than the pain of change for
Clark County, nothing's going to change
at the legislature. When I talked about
the toll road, met with I think eight
different
state representatives. Every single one
of them almost verbatim, that's a great
idea Ed, but and then in insert your
excuse here is why not to do it. Mostly
because it's a tax increase, I got to
get reelected in 2 years. And and that's
why we constantly have these people on
this 2-year cycle. If nothing if they're
not getting bitched at by the
neighborhoods, at least you know, we are
talking to our legislator, they know
what our problems are. But if the people
in Las Vegas are not talking to their
legislators and telling them that we got
a problem here or there, they're
oblivious to it and they really don't
care what happens up here because we
don't elect them down in Las Vegas. So
it's it's a hard lift, but relationships
will matter in the long run. It's it's
just [clears throat]
and then you got the turnover, too. So
I might be in the assembly for 6 years
and then decide I want to be a senator
for 6 years and then
then I'm out and then the next person
it's just a continual turnover. And you
want to really know who runs the state,
it's the lobbyists.
Lobbyists for the state of Nevada, they
run the state cuz when you get elected,
they're in your door telling you how to
vote and who to vote for and when to
vote and and then everybody wants to
have a bill with their name on it. So
I'm going to have
my my bill is going to be that I want to
name one street Ed Lawson Boulevard. So
I got a bill that will has my name on
it. So I'm AB 001 or whatever the number
is. So it's it's a complicated issue and
it's not just as simple as why don't you
just do something.
I'll start with that.
Thank you all very much.
I've been a Sparks homeowner for 20
years. I'm hearing you three say that
Sparks needs revenue, which is obvious.
What I'm also hearing is
let's raise taxes on the homeowner.
Let's charge tolls for the people
driving, which you said, well, let's
make USA Parkway employers pay it, but
the bottom line is the toll roads end up
getting paid by the common person.
So what I'm hearing you say is what
what I [clears throat] constantly see is
the little guy getting hit with extra
taxes, extra increases. My children
can't afford to buy a house right now.
My grandchildren can't afford to rent,
but let's raise property taxes or
blaming the legislature.
So let's uh well, my question to you is
let's take the legislature out of it.
Let's take the toll roads, the property
taxes out of it.
Our businesses I see getting tax breaks
coming into Sparks. Developers are
getting rich
and we're paying for the roads coming
in. So, I'd like you to think outside
the box a little. How can you raise
revenue in Sparks without charging the
little guy?
Well, there there is no way. So,
we can raise your trash fees, we can
raise your telephone fees. We're limited
by the state on how much we can charge
you for telephone service.
Uh we're limited
We have trash and there's one other.
Anyways, I mean, if you want to pay $300
a quarter for your trash, we may be able
to hire a couple extra policemen. It
doesn't seem that we can do that. So,
the the bottom line it's a structural
change. It's a structural problem. And
no, we can't change your property tax.
And what Charlene's talking about was
the tax resetting on sale of the home to
the value that you paid for it.
So, why should you get the benefit of me
living in my house for the last 30 years
and pay the exact same amount of taxes
you paid four times more than my house
and you're raising kids. My kids are
gone and they're contributing members of
society now. So, it's a fair tax.
Uh you know, we we have to raise some
fees. We went through all of our fees
recently and we had some that we haven't
raised in 15 to 20 years. We raised some
of those fees to come more in line with
what it should be. Yes.
I'm looking at fees for businesses and
stuff and not Yes. not the homeowners,
yeah.
Yeah, and and that's where a lot of our
money comes from is from business
licenses, the revenues that they
generate, we get a percentage of. I I
think she misunderstood the property tax
because we're talking about if you
if a new person buys your house, they're
going to pay the same tax rate as you do
without the appreciation showing at it.
So, if somebody new bought your house,
then that tax rate would go up based on
the current assessed value. It wouldn't
affect you. It wouldn't affect
>> is if my child wants to buy a new house
now, their payment's going to go up
another $100 a month because their
property taxes are going to go up like a
couple thousand a year, maybe.
>> But the city can't
do that. The city doesn't raise taxes,
only the legislature does. Like your
trash fee, your
uh sewage fee, that's what cities do.
They're the fees. But if your if your
child goes and buys a house and the law
changes
they're going to pay a higher tax if
that law would change to charge taxes at
the assessed value.
It's complicated, right?
>> [laughter]
>> It's It's extremely complicated.
>> So, is it so to kind of couple on that?
If your If your child buys a house in
the city of Sparks today
and they buy my 35-year-old house, they
get to assume my 35-year depreciated
taxes. If your child goes and buys a
brand new house in the city of Sparks
and they do the reset at
It won't be a reset. Actually, today a
brand new house is taxed at whatever is
taxed in full. You spend 300 or 500,000
today for a new house. You start your
taxes then and they start depreciating.
So, new new houses are taxed at the
value. It's any house any house an older
house, especially one that's been around
a while, has the depreciated taxes. So,
property taxes to buy my house compared
to buying a new house that's worth 5 or
600,000 would be substantially higher.
So, really as you're looking at homes if
they can buy a house that is that's been
around a while and actually
something
to really illustrate that that challenge
for the city, every house in the city of
Sparks that's older than 5 years old
isn't paying enough property taxes
for the services the city has to
provide. Fire, police, roads. The
builders, the developments build the
roads, but then they turn them over to
us for maintenance. So, all of those
fees that we have to come up with. And
as far as businesses, we aren't offering
tax breaks to businesses coming here,
but really the taxes that they pay
to the city
stays higher. So, we really gain more
from businesses and commercial coming
here than we do residential solely
because of the property tax system that
we have so many services to provide to
residents, which that's our job. But to
businesses, it's a higher tax rate, but
we're not giving the abatements that
they gave out of the Tri Center to bring
those businesses to Sparks. That's not
happening in the city.
Can I just follow up with one I just
want to clarify this.
During the Great Recession, my home went
from $250,000
to $90,000.
How much did it go back up after the
Great Recession? It can only go up 1 and
1/2%. So, all those taxes that we were
paying in 2008 and 9 when my house value
dropped in half, my taxes dropped in
half, but I can only go up 1 and 1/2% a
year. So, in essence, to get back to
where we were in 2009, it takes 25 years
to get back to the same revenue that we
had in that time. So, it's it's a
complicated issue and the partially
because
the state has made it convoluted and
it's got to be fixed somehow.
Otherwise, I'll tell you I'm going to be
honest with you. [clears throat] We're
going to turn the keys over to the city
of Sparks. We'll turn them over to the
state because we're going to be
insolvent.
Hi.
I've been in Sparks since the '50s,
raised children and grandchildren here.
Sorry. Sorry.
Uh
children and grandchildren here.
I lived up in old Sparks and since 2013,
I've been out on Pyramid Highway.
Um
I work in Carson City. Half of my
commute
is Pyramid Highway.
You know, to drive to work.
I have a hard time finding a place to
ride my bicycle.
And I'm not against growth.
But I'm I'm asking a I guess a
philosophical question here.
How do you balance growth
with quality of life
for Sparks citizens?
I have the same question.
Me?
>> [clears throat]
>> Um I
I witnessed
uh when we moved to Red Hawk
uh Vista was a two-lane road that ended
right there at that windmill. All right?
Uh
like I said, I started out as a
one-issue person trying to save Red Hawk
from developers.
So, they want to put more houses out
there.
But I'm I know that one of the reasons
that all this building's going on is it
because it brings property tax revenue
to the city.
And I think we're growing too quickly.
We can't go back. But I think we can
slow down some of the growth.
And I have to tell you
I'm funding my campaign only on
donations from people.
Um my campaign slogan is people over the
powerful.
And I have taken no developer money. I
have taken no casino money and I'm not
going to do it even when I get elected.
So, I am truly
an operation run by my partner, my
daughter, my neighbors and my friends
and even friends from grade school and
high school and college. They know what
I've done my whole life, so they're
supporting me. And I know I may not be
able to stop the Red Hawk development,
but I can sure as hell be vocal about
it. And represent those people out there
and until this horrible thing passes
because they're going to dig up our golf
course.
It's going to disrupt the ecosystem out
there. They're going to fill in five
lakes.
And
that's what started me on this
path. But a few weeks ago, I rode around
with the police department, so when I
get another minute or two, I'll talk
about my experience riding around with
the police department.
Charlene or me?
>> Yeah, Charlene next. Oh,
I've lost track which way we're going
here.
I know. [clears throat]
I'm good too. Um
That That is a million-dollar question,
really. Traffic number one, absolutely
number one is our traffic issue, which
is growth. And the growth that we've
seen the last census, Sparks grew by a
higher percentage than any of our
neighbors
in the area.
Almost 15% growth out here in Sparks.
And we can feel it. I mean, I was a
little girl who grew up
grew up off Pyramid McCarran where
Raley's Shopping Center was a cow
pasture.
Um
Vista that I live down Vista now in the
Vistas
was a dirt road that my husband rode his
Jeep with a German Shepherd running out
in front of it. So, the growth I've seen
in 62 years here
is real and what
the issue for us right now is the pain
the pain
the strain Excuse me.
>> [clears throat]
>> The strain on our infrastructure. So,
our infrastructure is strained because
of the growth. And the growth if I could
barricade I-80, you know, would I?
Maybe. But people are coming here
because of jobs, because of the growth
of the economy, because they're unhappy
in California for a number of reasons.
But that growth is coming in and we've
got a lot of jobs, but the
infrastructure that it's straining is
housing, it's roads and all of those are
quality of life, absolutely. So, how do
we try to manage that the best we can
and
and and provide more amenities, police,
fire, working on the roads the best we
can to keep up with it. I'm hoping it
slows down. I am not anti-growth at all,
but we do a lot of planning, regional
planning. People think things are just
thrown up and nobody thinks about it.
It's a very precise planning system that
in order to approve that growth and and
we just have to try to manage the best
we can and be aware of the impacts on
people and and I am, absolutely, and
it's top priority.
So, the the saying that I heard a long
time ago was live, work, play. Wanted
you to live where you work, where you
play, so that you're not making these
commutes to Carson City or to Tesla. You
know, is how do we provide that
business? Well, most of our city was
planned in the '90s and the early 2000s
by handbooks. And a handbook says what
you can build, where you can build it,
and how many of them you can build, and
even what colors they need to be. So,
those handbooks are nearly impossible to
change.
So, like for example, the Red Hawk
handbook, nearly impossible to change.
Not saying that it can't be, but it's
nearly impossible. So, these kinds of
things are how we look for the future.
The
lands bill that I've been promoting for
the last 12 years is grow east and mix
more commercial and industrial out
there, so that we're building the
widgets that goes to the Tesla truck or
to the Redwood materials or to the other
tech industries out there. They're
paying taxes in Washoe County, Sparks,
instead of paying uh Storey County
taxes. Now, we do get those employees,
85% of the people that work out there
live with us in Reno, Sparks, and 85% of
them live north of I-80. So, the need
for the road, need for the growth
towards the It's now 40,000 jobs. We
anticipate in the next year 8 years to
be 50 to 60,000 jobs out there. Unless
they decide to pick up and leave, and
then all these valuable homes that we
have now go in the dirt and people leave
that area. And I I mean, I hate to be
doom and gloom, but you have to be
practical at the same time. So, what How
do you balance all those things at the
same time?
Okay, thank you.
Any other questions?
I'm going to start with Charlene. Thank
you.
You wish I would? You.
Um hi.
Um
I am wondering what
everyone's approach is on solving the
homelessness in the town.
Um the mayor as is he's on the board.
The community advisory board, I don't
know if that's carried over if and when
he is because seems like we just have
excuses. But I'm wondering what you
guys' uh
approaches on that because we can't
We've been just the other side of the
invisible line, right?
An approach, right?
Thank you.
The The homeless issue is something the
City of Sparks has been um
really involved in
since
pre-COVID. Uh
we invested CARES Act money to create
that CARES campus
uh to provide
um a facility for our homeless
population, and um
we have been a huge supporter of that,
even though Washoe County, all of us who
live Reno, Sparks, and Washoe County,
our tax dollars go to Washoe County for
indigent services and for social
services. The cities of Reno and Sparks
have no obligation, a fiscal obligation
or an authority over that because it
falls under the county, but we believe
it's important enough that we have been
actively involved in financing the CARES
campus, in addressing the homeless issue
on a variety of working with HOPES of
Northern Nevada. We help donate to their
clinic there, and then our officers, our
HOPE team, uh are our officers that have
been on the river since 2019.
5 years now. So, 2020-ish. 2020-ish, our
officers that work uh
on along the river and in parks, and
it's a community policing model that has
been so successful that Washoe County
Sheriff's Department adopted it, and the
university police do also. And they
provide They work with the homeless
individuals to provide uh to to access a
variety of wraparound services. And each
individual they It's a slow process, one
person at a time. And that one person at
a time, somebody needs a driver's
license, somebody needs um
We We can't just put somebody in
housing. We've got to make sure all the
services are there. It's compassionate,
and we direct them to the providers, all
the agencies that do that. And we do
that through our um
through our HOPE team and through our
commitment to to help make a difference,
and we have made a difference in Sparks.
Um like I told you, I rode around with a
police officer all day on his shift, and
I went to the morning briefing, and the
two CARES officers were there, and
they're wonderful.
Um
during the time I was on patrol with my
officer, uh we didn't couple of the
calls we encountered were unhoused
people.
And
the police officers knew who these
people were,
and they talked to them, and they were
very kind to them.
So, I have no complaints about how our
officers and the city are treating the
unhoused because I witnessed it first
hand, and they're very nice, they're
very caring, and they asked the people
if they need any help. Most of the calls
were about trespassing.
I mean, there are people who just want
to live on the street. We had a
I worked at Round Table Pizza for a
while, we had a dough roller, and
and find, you know, find a place where
you can stay. And he said, "I just like
sleeping under my bush." And it was in
Sparks. So, there are people like that
that don't want to go to the center, but
I have to say that the program that
Sparks has and the police officers are
very kind to those people, and they know
most of them by their first name.
So, I have no complaints about them.
That's good. Yeah.
Uh
I think Charlene had most of it. The The
bottom line is the HOPE team is awesome.
It's It's a model we're trying to get
regionally because what happens, our
guys work for 4 days, and then there's
backfill, you know, when they're in
their 3 days off. So, we had a HOPE team
from the city of Reno, Sparks, and
Washoe County, we could be 24/7 and
really making a difference. But, the
other side of it is you have to have the
services. And if there's
We don't know what it is exactly, but
it's somewhere around 8 to 10 steps to
get out of homelessness. The first part
is get off the street into a shelter
where you can start to get care and and
or not sleeping under the stars. And
then it's starting to get care for your
addiction, whatever that is. And then
it's learning to balance a checkbook,
and then it's getting an apartment, and
then it's this. Well, if you get to step
seven, we don't want you to go all the
way back down to step one where you're
homeless again. We want you to fall down
from seven to five. And that's what the
CARES campus is doing. That's why it's
taking a little longer. As they've got
permanent supportive housing, they've
got housing there to address mental
health issues, addiction issues, and
literally how to balance a checkbook.
Almost every homeless person in America
gets a minimum of $800 a month. Some of
them We've heard as much as some of our
retired vets of four to five, six
thousand dollars a month in in checks
from the government, and they're still
homeless because they don't know how to
deal with their money. Or they're
addicted to something, and the drug
dealers then beat them up, take their
money, and and then it's just a a
vicious circle. So, I think we've done a
really good job with the CARES campus.
Are we finished? Absolutely not. Uh is
the county doing a good job? I believe
they are, making great strides. We're
not there, though.
Really?
Anyone that hasn't asked a question yet
that wants to ask one?
Okay.
>> [clears throat]
>> Donald doesn't get to ask.
I have no questions from Abbott.
Just to
pick up on the homeless issue when we
were talking to
my sister
uh pricing. I'd like your thoughts on
inclusionary zoning.
My what? Inclusionary zoning.
We don't know what that is. You're going
to have to give me an explanation. You
don't You don't know what it is, either.
Inclusionary zoning is when you, for
instance, a developer comes in
and set like, "Okay, 10%
of that development needs to be
affordable."
It can either be same location or
different location.
>> We We never called it that.
Okay, different naming. So, what are
your thoughts on that?
We do ask for that. As a matter of fact,
in Sparks, we have I think one of the
greatest uh
thing going on right now. Maverick uh
gas stations has a charitable arm, and
they uh want to build affordable housing
mainly for their people that work for
them.
But, they also want a a portion of it to
be subsidized housing. And and really,
what there is is
market rate and subsidized. All the
other names you want to put on it
doesn't mean anything. It matters if
you're getting money to to live there or
you're not paying as much money. That
That's what it is. Or otherwise, it's
market rate.
But, what they're doing uh there Marina
Gateway and and Prater, building
apartments with 30% AMI, average median
income, 50 or 60, and then uh 100.
And those are being supplemented, and
they're building a hotel right across
the parking lot. That hotel proceeds
will help supplement those rents. It's
an out-of-the-box way of thinking. They
came to us in Sparks and it was a
no-brainer to go, "Yes, we absolutely
think that's a wonderful idea."
Um I also think we need to help people
who've been in their current homes,
maybe in old Sparks, for a long time.
And there needs to be some kind of way
where people can age in place.
I know a lot of people are afraid
they're going to lose their homes and
have to move. Um my partner, John, he
was president of Habitat for Humanity.
And in order to help some of those older
homes and those families, I think maybe
the city should maybe uh do some
partnerships with nonprofits like
Habitat. And instead of building homes,
maybe help the people stay in their
homes and fix them up. So um and I also
know that the unions are building some
affordable housing. I I think off of
Clear Acre, that's not really Sparks,
but I think more opportunities like that
need to happen, too. And they can use
those for their apprenticeship programs.
But um
I have one little story. How much time
do I have? I worked for the Census
Bureau every month for 5 years. I
collected data for the jobs report. And
I had to go to homes all over Sparks,
from one end to the other. And one of my
worst experiences was
going to homes, apartments where
people's rent was $600 a month. This
went high.
Um
Tesla and all those companies started
moving in here and taking over some of
those apartments. And this guy was in
tears. He said, "My rent just went to
$1,000 a month. And I'm going to have to
move in with my sister.
But my sister won't let me move in until
my dog dies."
So I think a lot of that apartment
prices going up was also forcing people
out of where they lived at that time.
Um I'm not I'm I'm a little bit I I know
the state would have to do this, too,
but some kind of rent
control where that would affect families
and and low-income people.
So so really, yeah, the how housing is
one of the biggest biggest challenges uh
of many that we face and the
affordability of it. And
when you work, you know, and we've
worked with a lot of the developers that
are trying to build more affordable or
workforce workforce housing. You know,
it's not low-income Section 8 housing.
It's workforce housing that seniors
that veterans that a single mom raising
her kids can live in. And um
and a lot of those developers that
really are in that space or want to be,
um
if it doesn't pencil out, they're not
the bad guy. They can't, like any
business, if if if you can't make money,
not to be evil, just to simply, you
know, keep building more businesses,
uh it can't happen. So that's been a big
challenge. And a lot of the affordable
housing, the one up behind Summit Mall,
I was at that groundbreaking years ago
and it was the first one, the model of
they were doing the sliding scale, which
I loved that idea. So the single mom who
was a hairdresser, what her rent would
be compared to someone that could pay a
little more to full market, really that
sliding scale made a lot of sense. And
then we work the city works a lot uh
very closely with Reno Housing
Authority. We also work with some of
these developers. We just sold um a lot
on um 10th Street, 10th and Avenue of
the Oaks, that has that old house on it.
And we have the Northern Nevada Housing
Coalition that is going to build 40
apartments uh that are full that are
veteran preference. And and and then use
that that house for um services and uh
gathering center. But but we have little
parcels in Sparks. We've been able to
work with Home Means Nevada funding to
help those developers come in and build
that. We can't force them to, but we
know it's a need, so the more we can do
um
with with on the city side to work with
them to make that happen, uh the need is
greater than than what the, you know,
supply and demand. And there's far more
demand than there is supply, so we're
working every day to try to increase
that where we can.
Does anyone else have a question?
Oh, not you.
No, Donald, no questions. I think he's
got a question.
Oh, uh uh Oh, I'm not thirsty. He said
that.
Are you thirsty?
Perfect. I think you're going to ask me
first. Yep. Oh, well, if you want, I'll
take it. So obviously,
as long as you're in office, we uh we
always want to win, that's why we're
here. But if you are not able to win,
what will you do for Sparks in an
unofficial capacity?
I'll What What The question was, what
would I do for Sparks if I'm not
elected? Yeah, yeah, so obviously,
I asked you before you
were elected, what would you do to help
Sparks in an Since I've lived here,
I've been doing things for Sparks. I've
been organizing the community.
Uh we have neighborhood meetings. I know
the people who are my precinct
organizers and they're the heartbeat of
what I do and I'm not going to stop
doing that. And I'm not going to stop
training them. So I'm not going to
change much at all, except
be mayor and maybe have two new council
people.
And maybe some different things can
happen because
there's a good chance we'll get two new
people elected to city council and
there's a real good chance we might get
a new governor.
And my friend Neil Schwartz might get
elected uh to the legislature. So a lot
of us who are candidates have been
talking.
And we're not career politicians yet. I
don't know what makes a career
politician. Is that your first term or
second term?
I would not run again. I know that the
mayor position is not term limited, so
our mayor could be mayor for life,
right?
So So anyway, I would not change who I
am or what I do and I'm the same person,
except I have a driver now.
Well, I I If I don't get elected, I've
I'm going to devote myself to my
favorite charity, which my Rotary Club,
which we love doing things for kids. The
All Abilities Play Park at the Marina,
we were big instrumental in that through
my Rotary Club uh
raising about $150,000
of the $1.2 million project.
Uh we do fishing day at the Marina. Uh
I'm There's a myriad of things I would
love to do, but the first thing I'd do
is just retire. And and I promise you,
this is the last time I'm running for
office. I will not run again. This is
it. If we can't fix what I think needs
to be fixed uh in the short term, then I
would give it off to the next person
because we we're in such a bad way
statewide
that it's You can't really take time to
learn on the job. I know when I first
got elected, it'd take 2 years just to
figure out where you got to go to
meetings. And when you then serve on the
city council and between five and eight
more boards that are regionalized, you
have to be an expert in all of those
boards. It takes a lot of time. And then
you hold down a job and on top of that,
it really, when I first got elected, it
would 80, 90-hour weeks. So uh I'm ready
to retire after I feel like the job is
done or at least I've exhausted every
avenue to get things done. And I think
one of my qualities is I think outside
the box. And I got a call from one of
our constituents the other night. He
goes, "I have all these great ideas." I
said,
"Jeff, where do you think I get my
ideas? I steal them from guys like you."
Because he had the time to think about
it and make something happen. So
that's uh
I think that's the best part of it.
So this is my second chapter. I had 42
[clears throat] years as a flight
attendant. It was kind of like, "What
are you going to do when you retire?" Uh
decided to run for office in the city of
Sparks because I'd lived almost my whole
life there. Um
and I really
had been so involved in the community
and all my volunteering that I was doing
that I felt [clears throat] I was
invested in the city. And it was I was
actually looking at the state
legislature and somebody wisely talked
me out of that. Uh and and I'm just so
glad I made the decision I did uh to run
for city council. I also at the time,
there'd been very few women elected to
office in the city of Sparks. And my
husband coined a term that I used a lot.
And it was like there wasn't that there
weren't that Sparks didn't want women in
office. Women weren't running. They just
weren't running. Uh when I was elected,
Julia Ratti was on the council with me.
And then for 5 years, I was the only
female on the city council in Sparks.
When Reno was predominant, when the
legislature went to predominantly
female, when Washoe County was, and I
was kind of lone woman standing,
uh which was fine because uh but but it
was kind of the things that drove me
were not just because I was female, but
I felt that my voice was really
important. And Donald and I talked about
it. He was the voice of millennials and
I was the voice for women in the
council. So this is already my second
chapter. I've had a full career. Um so
if I don't win this office,
uh I'll jump back into all the community
volunteering that I do. It's uh Safe and
Healthy Schools Commission with the
school board.
Um I'll look at other organizations I've
been involved with or I'm sure I'll be
getting calls of people who want me to
step in and volunteer, but my commitment
to the community will always be there.
It's where my heart is. It's where my my
passion and time I've spent in my life
and uh that won't stop whether I'm in
office or I'll just have more time.
Thank you.
You have a question.
Um
Mr. Lawson, you said you're on the light
rail
Yes. study commission. I'm a non-voting
member of the board.
Um
when you talk about the toll road, I'm
cuz I'm a big advocate of light rail.
Uh
and
it's beyond me
to to try to understand
why we want why we aren't building light
rail instead of roads. I'll give you two
letters, UP.
Union Pacific.
Union Pacific sets the rules. So, Union
Pacific, I'll give you a great story. I
was talking with uh Kate Marshall when
she worked for uh President Biden. She
was asked to get an appointment with the
president of the Union Pacific Rail
and he declined to meet with the most
powerful man in the world.
That's how much power UP has.
They want us to build it to their specs.
We just had this study come out from the
RTC to transport 7,500 people in the
morning and 7,500 at night is a billion
dollars.
A billion dollars with a B. To So,
is we have to build the rails to the
standard where they could put heavy
freight on it and the grade and and the
terminals we'd have to have three
terminals. You start adding this up, it
adds up to real money.
What we're looking at at the statewide
is other places. Oh, plus you can't get
any financing if your uh rail is under
uh 750 miles long from the federal
government. So, we've pretty much and in
the state of Nevada, we don't have a uh
department that can control uh
a railroad.
So, we'd have to create a rail rails
uh
whatever you want to call it, my rail
department and then have that passed the
the state legislature and then figure
out how who was on that board. So,
that's that's years and years down the
road. But How how does like Washington
D.C. or the Bay Area Rapid Transit or
Atlanta Metro, you know, MARTA, how do
how do they get their systems built? No,
I'm going by what our consultants told
us that we don't get federal money to
build tracks off of that unless it's 750
miles. Maybe there's a combination of of
doing it all different pieces, who
knows.
But that's one of those other boards I
sit on.
I'm not an expert in. I just kind of try
to make the best decisions that I can
with the information provided.
I really can follow up on that.
The
you talked about the UP. Is that because
a light rail system which ran, say, from
here out to the parkway would be
adjacent to the UP tracks and property?
Yes, exactly. Is there any other place
that we could put light rail? No.
The slopes are too great.
Um if if we want to pass it with
Charlene, but I don't want to add
anything to that. I know that was a very
specific question, but I think those are
specific to him.
No, anything I might have specific to
me.
The Pinkertons?
So, I'll give you a quick story and this
is put a face on this. Donald has been
very much a historian of Sparks
and we wanted to save the maintenance uh
uh shack out out of the rail track. I
was on a motorcycle, I'm a avid Harley
rider, and I'm on a motorcycle ride and
I run into the guy who runs the Bureau
of Reclamation for Northern Nevada. He
goes, "Ed, I got 185 acres right
adjacent to Sparks. I'll give you that
land."
I said, "Can I trade that land with the
UP for the 2 and 1/2 acres in downtown
Sparks?" He said, "You do with it
whatever you want." I didn't get the
words out of my mouth before Union
Pacific said no.
They didn't want 185 acres adjacent to
existing track for free to just give us
two two and a half acres.
That's how much power they got. They do
their own thing.
Hm.
Any other questions you have or anything
like that you want to
Okay.
Thank you, guys. And I guess we're at
the point of wrapping up closing. Yes.
Um so, everybody's going to get 2
minutes to do their closing statements.
Um we'll probably start [clears throat]
with Charlene and then um we'll go this
way. So, after Diana.
Um so, yes, you have 2 minutes closing
statements, whatever you want to wrap it
up with before it.
Thank you all for being here. It's
always
it's [clears throat] always a great
thing to actually it's like I knocked on
how many doors this afternoon where I
would be out knocking on doors. I get
you all here, so I get to make eye
contact and then get a chance for you to
know me a little bit better. Um I am
running for mayor because I want to
continue to serve.
Um my focus is on putting people first,
like I said earlier.
I have the experience, not only 12 years
on the council, but 62 years in this
community and seeing the growth and the
changes, and I just feel like what I
bring to the table
um is people-centered.
Um
I'm obviously my other career
uh I talked for a living, so uh so,
[clears throat] I'm really good at
communication because it's what I do,
it's what I've always done is
communicate and listening to people. And
we might not be able to always um
to always say yes. Uh our motto has been
in the city of Sparks
uh to find a way to yes. So, if you come
in with an issue or business permit or
whatever you've got, instead of just
telling you no, we try to find a way to
yes. When you approach me with an issue
or question, I try to get a solution. I
might not always, but I'll listen and
I'll try to find a way
uh to find that way to yes, but if I
can't, at least you know that I've
tried. So, I think
uh the trusted I've been a trusted
leader
uh in Ward 4. I've been elected three
times with over 70% of the vote. So, my
voters are happy with the job that I'm
doing and I I I know that because I've
been there so long and I have their
support. And it's a hard time right now
with the Red Hawk situation, but I'm
listening and that's all, you know,
that's my number one job is to listen to
my constituents.
Thank you.
Well, I appreciate Charlene using my
slogan, find a way to say yes, I've been
using since 2010, but it has been a
philosophy that we have we have uh
we have
pounded into the heads of the our
employees because of some of the
systemic problems that we had. Um
we were doing a business license review
and I worked for Yesco at the time and
they said, "Oh, by the way, you haven't
paid your bill." I said, "Well, tell me
who I need to talk to and I'll get you a
credit card for it right now."
Oh, well, we can't accept credit cards.
I said, "What?"
So, we changed that system. These are
the little things that it I've been I've
been involved I retired from my other
job in 2017. I've been full-time council
since 2017. That's what I do. I get up
and I look for problems and ways to
solve those problems and I think outside
the box. Sometimes I think so far out of
the box that I get ridiculed for toll
roads. But you know what? Hey, I've
listed I'm at least looking for
solutions and sometimes they're not very
popular,
but at the same time, how do we get to a
place where we're structurally not
dying? I mean, we are literally dying as
a city and it's largely because of our
tax system in Nevada. So,
if you want to hear the truth,
talk to me. I'm happy to tell you the
truth and I'll tell you straight up the
the way I see it and if we disagree, try
and change my mind, but I'm I'm always
open to uh and my doors are always open.
I got I got maps all over the mayor's
office of the plans on the way to the
city to grow. Uh but you're welcome to
come anytime. My I have only one cell
phone. I don't have carry a business and
a personal, I carry one.
So, you call me, I answer my own call.
>> [clears throat]
>> I'm running because I think we need a
change and we need somebody who is
different from career politicians.
And sometimes if you get new people and
you get new city council people and you
get a new mayor,
it's good to think outside the box, but
I think way outside the box for most of
my body.
Um and I've been ridiculed for that one
time, too. I'll give [clears throat] you
one example. I worked for a company
where a person didn't want any African
Americans on his projects.
So, I started recruiting at Howard
University.
So,
sometimes
sometimes I'll do things a little
differently. One thing that makes me
really sad, I go to library board
meetings, I go to commission meetings,
I've been to city council meetings.
Nobody's there. Nobody goes. And I think
it's time because they're all frustrated
about raising money. I think it's time
to have neighborhood meetings,
town halls, Ward 1, uh Donald agreed to
that, right? We can come to your board
and have a town hall. Go to all five
wards maybe three or four times a year
and actually talk to the people because
they don't show up at those meetings.
And it really makes me sad because when
you do go, you go to county commission,
it's the same people over and over
again. I can name them all in my head
right now. Library board, the same
thing. So, I think as mayor, I would try
to energize people to show up at these
meetings, get on boards. [clears throat]
The boards the the mayor said the other
day they can't get people to show up on
boards. Another thing and I might have
to go back to them to get a an to this,
but there's a thing called the Charter
Committee. And the Charter Committee is
starting up there, and they come up with
issues to talk to the legislature. The
Charter Committee hasn't met for the
last two legislative sessions, and that
was one question I was going to ask, and
I need the answer to that.
They did have a meeting. That was last 2
weeks ago.
>> sessions before that.
>> No, they they met, but there was nothing
they wanted to put forward. Okay. They
didn't meet? Yeah, they're required by
the charter to meet before each
legislative system uh
session. So, they did meet, and then
there was nothing they wanted to put
forward, so
they uh called it a day.
Thank you guys so much. We appreciate
it. Um well, now that we're wrapping up,
uh
I also wanted to say just if you have
any more questions or information you
want from them, they're here, so feel
free to ask. And then you can check
their website for all of their
information and stuff like that. A a
couple quick things. If any of you need
to register to vote or change your
registration, Lynn will be outside.
[clears throat] She and I are both field
registrars. Um
uh George Guthrie from [clears throat]
the registrar's office apparently
couldn't make it, although I need to
find out why because
I thought we had everything in place.
But if you have questions about the
voting process, Lynn or I could probably
answer most of them. It is a little
wonky,
uh but there there are some things that
we can certainly tell you about how we
make things work. And um
thank you very much.
>> to answer something about the voting? Um
the registrar of voters has a a new
place, and it's beautiful. It's a
warehouse. They have new machines. Did
you go see the new machines?
Your ballot comes out, and you look at
it and make sure it's correct, and then
you stick it in another machine. I've
heard George Guthrie's speech several
times. And please go in person and try
out these new machines because I think
they're really state-of-the-art, and I
do want to say, and I think you'll
agree, the elections here are not
rigged, right? They they are absolutely
not rigged. There's a lot of
>> [clears throat]
>> you know, safeguards for it, but if if
somebody has questions, uh we will do
our best to answer that, and then I
guess there's Uh maybe a question. I
think you probably know this. You've
been voting
in the first
mayoral election. Is this the mayoral
election and the top two or else what?
The the top two people uh I think
there's one other person who's running.
The top two will advance to the general
election. Unless Unless one person gets
50 uh percent plus one. Right? Right.
So, May could be the race. June 9th.
June 9th. Early voting will start on May
23rd,
uh and you can go in in person. I think
you'll have a uh you should have
received by then uh your your mailing
ballot as well as a sample ballot. What
I like to do is to fill out my mailing
ballot,
go to the place. If the line is short,
I turn it in, and I use the machine. If
the line is crazy, I go to the drop box,
and I have it stamped and and uh put it
in.
Uh but I guess it's uh these these are
nonpartisan races. Everybody can vote
for the nonpartisans. That's why the
League is sponsoring a couple of forums
focused on the mayors. Uh there are a
lot of other races that are nonpartisan
as well, the judges and the council, but
there are a lot that are partisan. If
you want to vote in a particular person
in a partisan election, you have to be a
member of that party, um and you can
change day of. You know, okay, I've been
a nonpartisan. I'm going to change to
being a Republican so that I can vote in
this primary. And tomorrow I can change
back. Uh it's a little wonky, but um
you know, yes, you can. Uh and I I think
Doug has worked on a uh ballot question
so that the primaries are more open, and
that everybody can uh vote in
um all of the races, which at this point
cannot happen, but that's coming up
again, right? Hopefully.
Okay. I would also like to add um if you
want to read about all four of the
candidates, um the Reno Gazette Journal
just did a voter guide on the four of
them, interviewed them, asked them a
couple questions, so um you know, if you
want any more useful information.
>> And and and where would they find the
guide? You could find it on rgj.com, or
you could actually I think it might be
out in the papers now, but um Some of
it's been in the paper. Yeah.
Um
I keep up on this because I'm out
training volunteers. Uh the the
registrar in the state uh
the Secretary of State, they've removed
a lot of people from the rolls. They
haven't eliminated them, but if people
haven't voted in a certain number of
elections, they've been made inactive.
The last two federal elections. So, a
lot of people, I think it's around
30,000 maybe, who have been moved to
inactive. If you go to the polls and
they can't find you or they say, "Oh,
we'll look in inactive," you can
reactivate right there. But if you don't
receive a sample ballot next week or the
week after, call. Call them and make
sure they can reactivate you again, too.
And one other thing, if you sign your
ballot because they match signatures,
sign like it looks on your driver's
license. My friend's daughter's a
doctor, and her ballot got kicked out.
And I said, "What's wrong with Hannah?"
She said, "Oh, she must have used her
doctor signature." So, make sure you use
your your right signature when you get
those ballots because they'll kick them
out. And if I can just add one thing to
that, please make sure of this stuff. If
your signature has a problem, it goes
into what's called ballot curing.
If you
get something after you have voted from
the registrar of voters, do not throw it
away without looking. It's probably
telling you there's a problem with your
signature, and you need to correct it.
If you don't correct it, your ballot is
not counted.
So, be very careful with that with your
signature. Remember to sign, and if you
get something,
Yeah, you you can absolutely go in
person, and I've gone to homes to say,
you know, can we get them
because we
want everybody to have a vote,
everybody's voice to be heard.
Okay.
>> [applause]